foreign
[Music]
so everything everywhere all at once is
my favorite film of 2022 and I thought
what better way to close out the air
than when the big breakdown of the movie
in this video we're going to be going
through the film scene by scene to point
out all the hidden details Easter eggs
and Little Gems that elevate this above
most of the other movies released this
year in my opinion to me everything's
really well put together with even the
title sequence being something that
staggered throughout the film during
several shots that all Echo each other
now throughout the film we follow a
laundromat owner called Evelyn Who's
down on her luck after being called into
the IRS her husband's bodies possessed
by a man claiming to be him from the
alpha Universe he drafts her into a
multiversal war against the force known
as the jobu tabaki who has the potential
to destroy all Life as We Know It the
name gerbu tupaki is a bit of a weird
one and it was said by the creative team
that this was chosen because it's just a
bunch of sounds that don't mean anything
it's meant to be disjointed and
incomprehensible much like the
Multiverse itself and all the things
that exist within it revealed to be
Evelyn's daughter Joy jiobu was selected
by her mother to be someone who would
travel across the Multiverse and reach
out to all other forms of life
unfortunately I fractured her mind an
alpha Joy now exists everywhere all at
once she can see everything and nurse
through seeing all life she realizes
that nothing else matters it's kind of
like when you see those you are here
Universe memes and joy so everything is
being insignificant she then placed
everything onto a bagel and this in turn
created a black hole that can destroy
all life everywhere now a bagel being
used for this actually has a deeper
meaning Howard Bloom theorized that the
universe itself is shaped like this and
thus the idea that a bagel encompasses
everything has more to it there's also
this idea of bagel shapes which appear
throughout the film a bagel is it's a
circular shape and at the center of it
is another Circle A circles appear
throughout the movie constantly and we
open the film with a family singing
karaoke in a circular mirror after this
switches we see a circular fan with a
circle in the middle a circular light
with a circular ring in it and another
circular mirror wayman's face ends up
reflecting in this and it too carries a
deeper meaning at this point in the
movie the pair are slowly growing apart
a wayman's actually planning serving her
with divorce papers the pair being
separated by this circular mirror shows
how they're on the opposite side of
things and when we see the universes
later on they're too shown to be circles
thus there's the foreshadowing here that
wayman's in Another Universe and after
their initial talk Evelyn goes over to a
cookout that has a round lid with a
circular screw in the middle of it on
top of this we also have the googly eyes
that appear throughout the eyes are
circular and they have their own circles
within them now initially when we join
Evelyn in the opening there's just the
one bag that has the eyes on it this is
important as it represents Evelyn being
on her own however on the end of the
movie we get a repeat of this shot but
rather than being on her own she's
joined by her father husband and
daughter now as we said the first scene
just had the one set of eyes in well at
this scene at the end has four sets of
eyes just above the coat hangers we can
see a pair and this of course represents
her father to the top right of Evelyn we
can catch two sets and these two bags
are together representing her and her
husband lastly there's one to the right
of joy and this of course represents her
so the eyes all being together mirrors
is opening in which there's just the one
and it shows how the family has come
together now we are introduced to join
the next scene and this is done with her
staring into a tumble dry air or washing
machine look mate I'm not a washing
Appliance expert either way these of
course litter the laundromat and they
all have circular doors the way the
clothes are spinning here has them
sticking to the sides and thus they
create a circle within a circle
referencing The Bagel shape I guess what
deidre's character draws on the receipts
too that's right a black circle and the
followers of jabu topaki carry this
symbol on their heads to represent the
bagel when Alpha Wayman and Evelyn end
up hiding later on they also end up
eating bagels showing how like I've been
saying it's all connected also at the
tier 10 Mark we see the IRS Bagel
receipt that's sitting on the table
there's a calculator to the left and if
you look on the screen that's right the
number is five five three seven eight
zero zero eight flip that upside down it
says boobless and hey that's my favorite
Easter egg in this entire film now one
of the most creative things in
everything everywhere all at once is the
rapid fire montages that show Evelyn
throughout the universe so much work
went into the shot switch are on screen
for less than a second and there's so
much going on in them for this breakdown
I'll watch them in slow motion so we
could go through them bit by bit and
let's get into it now the first one has
Evelyn wearing a red jacket in a back
alley screaming next we have Evelyn and
her daughter looking over the bagel from
here we jump to here at the movie
premiere and this is in the universe
where she never went off with Waymond we
then have her with blood on her head in
the IRS building and this is where she
seemingly died at the midpoint from here
we jammed to her singing which is where
she gain the breath control now these
are all pretty standard and shown
throughout the movie however we next
jump to the universe in which Evelyn
died and we see her in an urn next to
her is a fish tank being played on a TV
screen and this is a similar setup to
the one that we saw at the start beside
the table next we jump to her working in
the universe in which she spun the sign
outside the pizza place this was used by
her so she could Spin The Shield later
on but the sign spinning is actually
foreshadowed at the start of the movie
when the family drive to the IRS they
actually passed someone doing it on the
street and Evelyn potentially ended up
as this person in Another Universe next
we cut to her in a universe where cats
are people and then look at her in the
desert judging by the suit in the back
this could be a nuke testing site and
Evelyn looks pale at don't tell Nolan
they test nukes in other universes
because you've already given that guy
way too many ideas now we then cut to a
horrifying world where she seems
fractured and her eyes are bleeding
black blood tying back to the nuke idea
we see a world that looks like it's in
the midst of chemical warfare with
Evelyn and gas mask an urban military
attire next she stands in front of a
wall of fire before we see her as a
horrible lizard-like monster next is a
bit of a standard one before we cut to
her as a nun and then what I'm calling
Star Trek Evelyn we then get an animated
World which is one of my favorite ones
from here we cut to Evelyn as part of
the universe and this reminded me of
Eternity from Marvel Comics and from
here we go to the hot dog finger
Universe where Evelyn's actually in a
relationship with Deirdre this shows how
in the Infinite Space that is the
Multiverse that even our enemies can be
our closest friends and it helps Evelyn
to later understand how important it is
to be kind to people in this universe
Deidre is the best thing that's ever
happened to her and she has the
potential within her to be to become
that in some way deidre's clothes are
really interesting and the design for
this was actually inspired by a
real-life IRS stock photo now after a
return to the cinema we see Evelyn as a
man locked up in a jail really
interesting shot before we transition
back to the jiobu tupaki scene before
jumping into her in a neon world with
her shoulders resting on a light and
black tape around her fingers we get
some reoccurring shots before we jump to
a really creepy one here we catch what
appears to be a murder scene with
forensics working in the background and
police tape lining the area Evelyn has
her eyes closed and this represents her
being the victim we then jump to her on
a herd before seeing her blended into
what appears to be a military airplane
camera used on either missiles or guns
next his hair is a little dog before we
jump to her dolled up looking like she's
part of the Rio Carnival more repeated
shots before we see her looking like
she's part of the member berries and a
shot of her also wearing a casa we then
jump to a shot of her and Asian dress
before jumping to one of the great
in-jokes in the movie here we catch what
appears to be a zoom call with Evelyn
against the green screen now this is
actually the VFX team that worked on the
movie and this is them brainstorming
what to use in the scenes here we can
see five artists and what makes the
movie even crazier is that just by VFX
artists did 80 of the special effects
for the entire movie next time you watch
a big Marvel ADC film look at how many
bfx artists are listed in the credits
and compared to this glad these guys got
the props they deserve and that they got
included in the movie too as VFX artists
in general are often overlooked now from
here we jump to Evelyn as a statue
before seeing her standing on a beach in
front of a burned out Pier I actually
think that this is Bryden which has a
burnout Pierre as one of its many
landmarks after jumping back to the IRS
fight we go to another world that looks
like it's ravaged by chemical warfare
but this time Evelyn's wearing a
different type of suit and gas mask now
whereas she was a nun in Another
Universe here we see her either as a
priest of vicar before we jump to her as
a tree next we catch her back in the IRS
building at a different part of the
movie before catching her in a snowy
Street and then we jump to a completely
different actor used for Michelle yo
this shows that in the Multiverse people
can even be played by different actors
and you might not know but originally
this movie was meant to be starring
Jackie Chan as Evelyn not wasn't playing
Evelyn well obviously it was he was
playing a guy but it just shows how
things can change and in the Multiverse
anything is possible now next we jump to
her with a short blonde bob cut lighting
up a candle and wearing a tracksuit
maybe though the father and none thing
was weird we then see a skeleton and a
nuns outfit taking it to the next level
from here we see Evelyn hurling up a
sweater over her face and this is in the
middle of a Polaroid next we jump to her
as an alien and can see pyramids are
flirting in the background there's long
been a theory that Ancient Aliens helped
Humanity build the pyramids due to the
size and scale of them and this will
could indeed show that it was in fact
aliens but from here we go to Evelyn
drawn and chalk on some Easter eggs
which is an Easter egg before we go to a
Twin Peaks reference huge shout out to
John Morris on our Clips channel for
pointing this out and we can see the
words meanwhile along the bottom with a
white statue in the background it's
similar to the show now after more shots
of other parts of the movie we get a
really good in joke here is a YouTube
video about Illuminati symbols hidden in
Hollywood films for one frame this is of
course the summer Illuminati symbols
hidden in the movie and hey a nice work
guys anyway more shots continue the
Montage and we get a really weird one
with Evelyn as a man who looks like he's
called Ian or Dave or something no idea
what this is but they love tennis they
bloody love it but they hit the thumbs
up button and also subscribe to the
channel as well next we get an
impressionistic painting of Evelyn
Multiverse of Madness showed us every
Multiverse has got to have a paint world
and this is of course theirs with
anchored to Evelyn wearing an 80s
digital watch with her eyes looking out
from behind her hands we then see Evelyn
as a little baby before jumping to her
in a nightclub and then a world in which
he's sort of wearing a white Domino mask
over her face next is a nun world where
she has several markings on her face
before we see lanterns flying up behind
her the Xena world where it looks like
Evelyn is the center of the Multiverse
and thus we have a Multiverse that has a
reality with its own Multiverse in it we
then cut to her on some planes with what
I believe a buffalo is behind her before
jumping to a picture of a house with her
face flowing above it following on from
this we get a creepy pasta worthy image
with Evelyn screaming as a woman in a
cat suit stands behind her there's a
picture of a cat and a hat behind her as
well and I hope this is a Halloween
costume or it's one of the most
terrifying universes ever created and
the Montage following on from this just
has Evelyn with different backgrounds
showing some of the worlds we've already
visited with a couple of ethereal ones
dotted throughout and that's it I feel
like I need to lie down after that after
the introduction to the characters we
see joy and also her girlfriend Becky
Joy then drops his line about how her
mother might call her father something
in case my mom says something dumb like
fat or whatever
I thought you said when she says [ __ ]
like that I mean she cares
this pays off later in the movie with it
also being something that Evelyn uses to
instill Joy twice in the car park you
you have to try and eat healthier
you are getting fat you are getting fat
and you never call me even though we
have a family plan this shows she cares
and it sets up her amazing monologue at
the end of the movie a customer ends up
complaining and then later we see Wayman
dancing along with him wayman's entire
outlook on life is that people should
treat people with kindness and this is
one of the first instances of this now
Evelyn goes back into the room we see
that the clothes bag she gets has a
number 42 on it this is potentially a
reference to Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy in which we learned that 42 was
the answer to everything Evelyn also
drops a line here where she basically
says that Wayman probably wouldn't have
survived without her but we're in the
movie star Universe we see what his life
would have been like and we learned that
he's in fact being a successful
businessman now in the laundromat we can
see a TV in the background playing a
movie this is starring Sunita Manny who
actually has a connection to the Daniels
Daniel cuando acted the music video for
Turn Down For What and Sunita actually
starred in this Evelyn turns around and
we can see a little advert up for
singing less with her as we discussed
earlier there exists a world in which
she became a singer and the theme that
Evelyn is multi-talented is summing at
slice throughout the film in the IRS
building we all see that she's tried to
claim a lot of her Hobbies as business
expenses as to how as a laundromat owner
a karaoke machine a constitute a
business expense you're also a novelist
and a chef last time you talked a
singing coach and a watsu technician I'm
sorry I love this little touch as it
shows how many interests that she has
and it foreshadows all the different
versions of her across the entire
Multiverse Evelyn sits down with her
father at the table and to cement the
googly eyes thing we see some above the
cardhanger for a father and two bags
above her the blue one has big googly
eyes on it and to the left of it we can
see the white one which has them too
there are actually three people in the
scene as we have her father gong gong
Evelyn and if you look in the mirror on
the right you can see Wayman in the
reflection we then go to the IRS where
Wayman sees an elderly couple kissing
each other this is a life that he very
much Longs for and it's brought full
circle at the end of the movie when
Evelyn Wayman kiss in the same spot in
the elevator Alpha Wayman takes over and
he pops up an umbrella with with donuts
on it which look it's not exactly a
bagel but but it is Bagel shaped and
we're still going to be doing more
circles in the video so shut the [ __ ] up
now Wayman gives her the choice to turn
left or right and it's decisions like
this that create vastly different lives
for people one minor change can have
massive repercussions and we see
Evelyn's Life playing out in front of
her her father was disappointed she was
a girl and she chose to move with Wayman
to America to open up a laundromat she
gets pregnant with joy too who of course
is also a girl but in an opposite to her
father Wayman is actually happy rather
than going to the closet Evelyn carries
on and we see the staircase where it all
goes down at the end Daniel Quan
actually cameos in the climax and he's
the first person to be sucked into the
black hole Bagel he also appears during
the Hollywood scene and he's the first
person who's clapped in the face by the
Kung Fu Master after robbing Evelyn down
in Alleyway now upon the travel tune
alternate reality being activated Evelyn
looks into a round circular mirror these
then pull back through the office and
the creative team said they did this to
reference the Buster Kingdom film
Sherlock Jr they said a scene in which
the background for someone changed
whilst the character in it managed to
stay static it's something it happens
throughout the film and the directors
captured a lot of the background by just
walking through the streets of New York
and filming stuff on a GoPro this was
then sped up with Michelle yo being over
a green screen which added to her being
pulled through the realities and the
Kirby she jumps back and forth between
worlds and we get some amazing lines of
dialogue that reflect one another but I
cannot imagine anything mattering more
then the conversation we are now having
and nothing could possibly matter more
than this conversation will happen right
now concerning the fate of every single
world of our infinite Multiverse Deidre
well we call him Deirdre in the film
they call him Deirdre so sorry if I keep
going there wrong deidra's Awards also
look like butt hugs which we'll say
because YouTube's been demonetizing me
recently and later on there well they're
sort of used in that way which is
clearly a comment on the IRS shafting
people when it comes to money Deidre
sends her home to get her Affairs in
order and another weird picture of a cat
can be seen on her desk when we later
jump to the hot dog world with her we
can also see pictures of cats hanging up
in her home and maybe that's what the
Montage was referencing earlier after
Evelyn hits Deirdre it all kicks off
with Wayman busting out the bum bag Kung
Fu bum bags but we're in America so a
word of warning then
out there they call them fanny packs
because Fanny means you're ass over
there
you Mitch
now this was actually chosen by the
directors because they wanted to play up
the Asian stereotype of a tourist father
who carries around a bum bag with them
this could also be a nod to data's
Gadget belt and The Goonies who was also
played by kehuan he decks them all
including the security guard who we end
up seeing a bit too much of later on
there's also an appearance by Andy Lee
and this pair actually on a YouTube
channel called Marshall club which has a
video showing some behind the scenes
stuff on the film after the fight we
also get a reference to Terminator I'm
not the waymer who wants to divorce you
I'm the waymer who is saving your life
and you can either come with me and live
up to you on to my potential or lie here
and live with the consequences come with
me if you want to live now in the
alternate reality we meet jiobo tupaki
and also see Evelyn as a baby who's then
pulled through the universe before she
gets killed Joy changes Reality by
clicking her head and in two split
second shot so we see Two Worlds the
first has a spray painting a circle
within a circle and this of course wants
more represent sense The Bagel the
second one has her about to head into a
head-on collision and this could be
because Joy was jumping through worlds
and made hellu's control now I don't
really see how else she'd get out of
this she's pretty and just in the same
way that a version of Evelyn has just
died it shows that there are echoes
across the Multiverse with Joy Living in
reality where she's about to die too we
get some stuff built in on the alphabus
and we see Wayman in the back of an RV
this is actually the laundry delivery
truck and it's what we saw the family
driving to the IRS in rather than a guy
spinning a pizza sign though we instead
see a homeless man with a cardboard sign
that says hail Bagel the bear they're
making of the stairwell which is when
Alpha Wayman starts to discuss the bagel
he says the clothes never wear as well
the next day
the hair never Falls in quite the same
way this is actually a reference to the
song nine days by absolutely
[Music]
at this point Deirdre attacks him and
Wayman starts giving himself paper cuts
to transfer into another Universe I
don't know I hate watching the scene now
I always view them as having to do
something weird because it's so
off-kilter from the path that they're on
that it actually opens up other paths
and allows them to scene of the universe
so that they can start to navigate it
this is why we get so many weird things
and the weirder it is the further the
path opens up Wayman explains it like
like doing something weird puts you on
the edge of the universe which then
opens a path so you can travel into
others Evelyn fails the first Gem and
she ends up in a car park outside the
IRS discussing her divorce I absolutely
love this line which of course matches
up with what's happening on screen
emergency
Tony you always get pulled away
Wayman ends up leaving her which The
Other Women thinks is referring to the
divorce he's ready to split because he
doesn't think she's the right person
however Deirdre still continues the
attack Wayman starts to question whether
their lives would be better if they'd
ever got together and this is when we
see Evelyn defending herself from Deidre
here we get shots from the real Michelle
Yo's life which are used to the backdrop
of her being a movie star interestingly
the character for the film was
originally called Michelle but yo had
this change because it was just too
close a training begins and we see a
sort of Kill Bill Kung Fu Montage where
she starts to level up later on this
ends up helping her to strengthen up her
little fingers and she uses this to bust
someone up they actually use a sound
effect from Smash Brothers for this
moment which is such a cool Easter egg
[Music]
now though I'm saying it's like Kill
Bill it's also clearly just ripping on
70 Style kung fu movies with us even
getting the grainy sort of footage that
was coming in the era the teacher also
says that even this cookie can be Kung
Fu and this is a similar thing to what
she gave Deirdre at the start the cookie
itself is also a circle with a I'll stop
now we we see her on the catwalk and
even get shot of her premieres in the
background we can actually see one for
crazy Rich Asians and there's several
clips from real life used for these
moments at the premiere we can also see
that the movie they're watching is
everything everywhere all at once with
Evelyn being a character so we have a
movie within a movie within a movie
anyway Deirdre is defeated and Evelyn
meets the waymen of this universe now
the scenes with the pair are actually
based on the film In the Mood for Love
This is a scene in which a couple speak
in an Alleyway which Echoes how women
and Evelyn talk with each other here Joy
arrives dressed as Elvis walking a pig
and this is where the movie starts to
get even crazier Joy face swaps sides on
her head and it comes through the back
of her hair which is again is a
reference to the switch scene that the
T-1000 does in Terminator 2. she is a
god able to turn bullets into steam
possibly referencing the comedian
turning Dr Manhattan in Watchmen Evelyn
is transported the hot dog universe and
here we get a homage to Stanley
Kubrick's 2001. that movie opened with
monkeys at the dawn of civilization and
we see how the hot dog fingers went out
in evolution to form the basis of this
world after this Joy transfers her
through to the bagel and we see this
imagery repeated in the architecture
that surrounds it with two circles being
to the left and right of it here Alpha
Joy reveals what the bagel is and also
what she's doing Alpha Joy doesn't want
to kill her mother she wants to find a
version of her that can travel through
the Multiverse to the level that she can
finally she'll have some common ground
with her and very much gain the mother
that she was unable to have in all of
the universes where she pushed her out
of her life she wanted to to see if
Evelyn would see something that she
didn't and thus bring meaning to her
life in the end Evelyn finds a purpose
to the pointlessness of reality and says
that we're all that we have so we have
to look after each other this is
inspired by wayman's speech which states
that we're all alone and thus we have to
look after each other and also be kind
we are told by Alpha joy that she put
everything onto a bail but when listing
off the contents she states things like
this all my hopes and dreams my old
report cards
every breed of dog every last personal
ad on Craigslist the opening of these
items Fall From Hell life and it very
much represents the hopes and dreams
that she had but was forced out of
having through Evelyn pushing her down a
certain path this black hole very much
represents the pain within her and this
has become an all-consuming void that
will destroy all meaning in the
Multiverse the film culminates with joy
wishing to travel into this metaphor for
her becoming lost in the nihilism of
what she feels inside Evelyn however
realizes that she can make everyone
happy and all those that have tormented
her throughout the movie become people
actually transforms by using their
innermost desires to help to change them
now from here we meet Alpha gong gong he
goes inside Richard Long's office and we
can see a black circle-shaped ornament
we can see on his desk that his name is
Richard Long and Richard long is
actually played by one of the directors
Daniel shinert his name is Richard Long
which is of course a play on Dick long
and he also has a little thing hidden
behind his desk now Joe is left free
while sajobu attacks the van in the
alpha world and at this point Evelyn
talks about rakakuni this is her getting
the story of Ratatouille wrong however
in the vast and infinite Multiverse
there of course exists the world where
this is real her saying this could
actually show that she was
subconsciously aware of this world after
jumping through several of them Alpha
gong gong gives Upland a box cutter
because he wants her to kill Joy while
she still can this will mean that she
will have one less Universe to move
around in because she'll be dead here
the safest universe is actually the
Hollywood one and this is for a number
of reasons not only are the events of
the film an actual film itself but joy
never existed in this world because
Wayman and Evelyn never got married they
never had joy and thus Alpha Joy cannot
appear here which is why she's
completely absent from all the scenes
with them in Evelyn goes over to her
with a blade but she sets her free
instead gangon calls in his forces and
Evelyn develops her skills which they
all do by downloading things into their
brain she sees a world in which she runs
too fast and falls on a stick which ends
up blinding her being able to navigate
the world whilst blind means that she
sort of becomes like Daredevil and
doesn't rely on her side which would be
blinded by the tear gas whether these
skills are downloaded is also very
similar to The Matrix and which
characters could download skills
directly into their brains as she exits
we also see another circular ornament to
the left of the painting which I'm just
pointing out I'm not saying it's
connected to anything and she busts up
some heads and even fights the woman
with the dog who swings the dog around
like you know you also get a close-up on
the IRS award and can see the name James
White on it this is actually the
post-production coordinator on the movie
which is a nice little inclusion for
this pot now from here Alpha Wayman is
killed by jobu and Evelyn dies after
vomiting this fully breaks the fourth
wall where the credits beginning to roll
and the Daniel's name pops up on screen
which is sort of another Cameo by them
Evelyn watches his play out and it could
be a reference to to the 2005 film
paprika this had a character in the
cinema watching the movie they were in
and it had a similar framing device to
what we see here across the Multiverse
she hops from world to world and it's
similar to how the geobu tupaki moves it
puts her mind in a constant state of
chaos and in a nice couple of moments
you see her as part of a jiri and also
on a bus eventually she heads back to
the laundromat namely world where she
just left the IRS the New Year's body
begins and the idea of New Year is very
important for the film it symbolizes new
beginnings and making changes which
Evelyn and the family end up doing from
this point onwards as she meets jobu and
his walk through alternate universes
including one that looks like feudal
Japan is a prison and a cartoon world
before they become pinatas Joy grabs a
branch that transforms into a weapon and
amongst these changes is an 8-bit one a
flag with a donut on it it circles again
a number one glove and lots of different
things that are on screen for a split
second Evelyn is taken to the San enter
where the bagel is held and he's given a
book titled everything everywhere all at
once which has a cover with Evelyn on
the front standing in a black circle
Evelyn ends up looking into the bagel
and we get a close-up of her eye which
is once more a circle within a circle at
the laundromat Evelyn also signs the
divorce papers and we see some circular
coins with holes in the middle once more
representing the bagel and how nothing
now matters to her she doesn't care
about the IRS coming in to seize her
business and exposes rakakuni before she
stabs Waymond at the laundromat Evelyn
asks what she's doing and we can see
that she has a necklace with a circular
pendant with a hole in the middle and
Deidre also wears a ring around her
necklace keep telling you circles
everywhere now Evelyn starts to believe
that nothing matters and she's arrested
at this point she's transported to a
world where the conditions went right
for like to Boom when discussing this
moment the creative team said that this
was actually based on the children's
book Sylvester and the Magic Pebble
eventually Wayman pulls her back from
going into to the bagel and we get some
flashes of their happy moments together
even the highly successful Wayman says
that in another life he would have loved
just owning a laundromat and doing taxes
with her he embodies happiness and even
his dustpan has a smiley face on the
back of it he and Evelyn Embrace and job
ends up pulling her back love the
details we have on her and we can see
that she styled her hair so that it says
jobu behind her we can also catch one of
her followers holding Chopsticks and
these are nested between his fingers
making him look like he's about to do a
wolverine The Bagel is brought in and
Evelyn takes on joby's forces she looks
into them to see what pain and anger
they felt and heals them of it we
learned that Deirdre ended up getting
divorced as well and this made her angry
so she can relate to Evelyn's breakdown
at the laundromat you also see the hot
dog version who has to play piano with
her feet because they obviously have hot
dog fingers don't know why in this
universe they didn't just invent
something else other than the piano but
moving on we have a moment where Evelyn
wipes away her tears with her feet and
to the left of Deirdre we can see some
hot dog-shaped gloves Evelyn is shot at
and she stops the bullets again
referencing Neo in The Matrix there's
one digging into her head and this is
similar to the scene in the first X-Men
movie She transforms his bullet into a
third eye and places it on her forehead
third eye is typically denote
Enlightenment and the ability to see
beyond the plane that we exist on the
third eye was also used in the
Multiverse of Madness to show this as
well it's kind of funny how he had two
Multiverse movies that drop really close
to each other that both use this device
Evelyn makes the first two people she
grabs fall in love and follows this up
by snatching the customer's grenade and
turning it into a perfume bottle the
wife used to wear that exact same
perfume digress her soul the SWAT team
member's neck problem is fixed and
Richard Long gets gagged and then
smacked Evelyn then grabs the chef and
they go after rakakuri which is what the
guy really desires everyone is given
something they want including the Kung
Fu master who also gets a cookie Evelyn
confronts her father and tells him that
even if he can't be proud of who she is
that she herself is she tells gong that
Joy is gay and refuses to ostracize her
like how her father did to her whether
Joy pulls away from this and she and
Evelyn end up fighting across the
Multiverse they return to Brighton
Pierre go to an airport and fight in a
courtroom as well as a number of
locations from before in the car park
Joy wants to go their separate ways
which is of course metaphorically shown
by her traveling into the bagel Rock
goes off the cliff Evelyn steps in and
all seems lost however Evelyn has a
change of heart and though she thinks
their life's a mess She'll always be
there because this is the time she has
with joy though the Multiverse is hectic
they do get a few specks of time where
it all makes sense and they finally
realize why they exist together they
will cherish those moments and across
the Multiverse we see is Evelyn helps
the chef gong gong accepts Becky Wayman
in the movie star Evelyn are brought
together and Hot Dog's fingers get up to
what could be some hot dog finger now
they start off the next day on a new
foot and Evelyn wakes up appreciating
everything she has though she's tempted
by being pulled away into another
reality she chooses to remain in the
moment she's undistracted happy and
content where she is ready to embrace it
all and live her life to the fullest
this was a lot to put together and huge
allows to our editor Stephen and Matt
for getting this all done in the space
of two days I really hope you guys
enjoyed it and make sure you drop a
comment below about your favorite part
of the film if you want something else
to watch then we have a big breakdown on
screen right now and I hope you all have
a great Christmas and New Year if you're
watching this in 2023 all the best for
that too and if you're in 2024 then make
sure you send me the lottery numbers for
the past two years yeah get them on an
email right now anyway thanks for
sticking through the video I'll be poor
let's see you next time take care mate
bye